Au boulot, Templeton
Salut, sublime Baby Corp.
- Oui, boss ?
- Au rapport
- Salut le frère du boss
Est-ce qu'ils sont toujours aussi sympas ?
Mon propre frère ne peut pas ignorer le sens des affaires. C'est gênant.
Je m'assure que le monde aime les bébés.
Plus encore que les chiots et les chatons.
Monsieur ! L'amour pour les bébés chute !
- Quelle est la menace ?
- Un chat !
- Quoooii ?
Les chats ne respectent aucune règle.
Le sort de notre entreprise est entre tes mains d'incapable.
Ne foire pas. Nan je rigole, tu foireras. Ca gaze ?
Cette réunion me met mal à l'aise.
Boss, on fait quoi ?
Je vais capturer ce tigre.
Vous vous amusez bien avec ton frère ?
Rein de suspect, je vous aime. Bye.
Mon boulot est en jeu.
Tu as fais un choix.
Tu as intégré une famille,
On peut arranger ça.
Et si tu cassais des objets pour accuser les chatons ?
Oui ! Une étoile dorée pour Staci.
Bon en vérité, c'est le chat qui a eu l'idée.
Caca ! Boudin !
Tu ne pas tuer ce que tu ne vois pas !
C'est l'heure de devenir...invisible !
Quand j'pense que maman m'a menti